the country has been in turmoil since
the army removed elected leader huang
sang soo chi from power
hundreds of thousands of people are
demanding a return to democracy
the un has condemned the crackdown
according to the human rights u.n human
rights office to date at least 138
peaceful protesters
including women and children have been
killed in the violence since february
1st
the secretary general strongly condemns
this ongoing
violence against peaceful protesters and
the continuing violation of the most
basic human rights of the people of
myanmar
the secretary-general uses call on the
international community including
regional actors
to come together in solidarity with the
people of myanmar
well let's bring in journalist andrea
nuckhamson in yangon andrew
the un as we heard calling for
solidarity with the people of myanmar
is that good enough for the people on
the streets
no it's to put it simply it's not good
enough
um the people have been expecting a lot
more support from the international
community i think they've been
pretty disappointed by the response and
there's been some
really clear things that countries can
do as outlined by the un's special
repertoire on human rights
for myanmar which includes imposing
targeted sanctions on
military conglomerates and helping to
build a more
coordinated global arms embargo to
prevent the military from getting
weapons andrew families are burying
their loved ones today who were killed
in sunday's clashes
in light of the rising death toll do the
burmese people still think it's worth
the risk taking to the streets
it's a tough question uh to answer i
mean we're definitely still seeing some
people turning out
um there's a protest going on in
mandalay right now which has been one of
the most
hardcore protest sites but we also have
seen over
over recent weeks the protests starting
to get a bit smaller
um which is understandable at the same
time i think a lot of people
are more focused on the civil
disobedience movement the the mass
strikes and the
um civil servants refusing to work for
the junta i think a lot of people feel
like that's really
the most important battleground and the
protests are kind of supplemental
amid all of this deposed leader huang
sangsuchi was due to appear in court on
monday
but that hearing has been cancelled are
there any updates on her trial
and indeed her condition
we haven't heard anything directly about
her
um her attorney actually said that he
still hasn't been
granted power of attorney by by the
courts um
which is obviously problematic and
um he hasn't been allowed to meet with
her in person he's only been allowed to
meet with her over video length
and those video links weren't working
yesterday and that also
poses an additional problem in that
basically any of his meetings with onsen
tsuchi
are going to be you know supervised by
military regime representatives who are
going to be you know watching and
listening to that video call
andrew knuckles in yankon thanks so much
thank you